-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We've missed you all
a great deal.
Let's get to the news.
Well, last night was
the closing ceremony
for the 2020 Tokyo Olympics,
which, because of COVID,
were actually held in 2021,
which means it's only three more
years until the 2024 Olympics
are postponed to 2027.
[ Laughter ]
The 2020 Tokyo Olympics
ended yesterday
and U.S. athletes brought home
39 gold medals,
41 silvers, 33 bronze,
and four new variants.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden on Saturday
held a Zoom call
with Team USA Olympians
and, if you thought winning
a gold medal was tough,
try explaining to a 78-year-old
man that he's muted.
"No, Mr. President.
I know you can hear me.
I-I can't hear you."
The United Nations
today released
a new report on climate change
and I don't want to say it's
bad, but this was the cover.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden announced
a new goal last week
that half of all vehicles sold
in the country by 2030
should be electric and,
for some reason,
the other half should be
vintage Stingrays.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Everything's heating up,
so you got to keep it cool.
[ Laughter ]
The Rolling Stones
recently announced
they'll go back on tour
in September,
after it was put on hold
last year due to the pandemic.
It's actually the second time
it's happened to them.
[ Laughter ]
Disney World last week
unveiled designs
for its new "Star Wars"-themed
hotel that will open next year
and feature
an immersive experience.
Though, if you're a fan
of Disney and "Star Wars,"
the only thing you haven't been
immersed in is society.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Crocs
recently filed lawsuits,
against Walmart
and nearly 20 other companies,
that claims they copied
their popular shoe style.
Said Walmart,
"That's a pasta strainer."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, the ice cream
company Marble Slab
recently announced a new
collaboration with Frito-Lay
to create a Hot Cheetos-flavored
ice cream.
Well, technically, it was also
a collaboration with weed.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
And, Marble Slab,
if you're watching,
"Seth Meyers Ice Cream"
still available.
[ Laughter ]
No movement at all from our
friends at Ben & Jerry's.
[ Laughter ]